Hey, smart list listeners, it's Sean Hayes with some exciting news. One of our smart list media shows is back with a brand new host. I'm talking about the one and only Bad Dates. And for season two, it's hosted by the hilarious Joel Kim Booster. You might know Joel from Apple TV's LÜT, Hulu's Fire Island, his Netflix comedy special, or his very revealing guest role on HBO's Industry. This season, he'll be your guide through all of the iconic and painfully true bad date stories that his guests reveal with all the gory details you loved in season one.
嘿，SmartLess的听众们，我是肖恩·海耶斯，有个激动人心的消息要告诉大家。我们SmartLess媒体旗下的一个节目带着全新的主持人回归了。我说的就是独一无二的《糟糕约会》（Bad Dates）。第二季将由搞笑天才乔尔·金·布斯特主持。你可能在Apple TV的《LÜT》、Hulu的《火烧岛》、他的Netflix喜剧特辑，或者他在HBO《行业》中那个非常抢眼的客串角色中认识他。这一季，他将带你领略那些标志性且令人痛苦的真实糟糕约会故事，他的嘉宾们会揭露你在第一季中喜爱的所有细节。
And we'll still hear real letters and voice messages from listeners sharing their own worst dates, plus Joel will weigh in about his own lengthy and bizarre time in the dating trenches. We love this show because everybody has had them, everybody can relate to them. And now it's time to laugh at them on season two of Bad Dates with your new host, Joel Kim Booster. Check out this clip from the show and follow Bad Dates wherever you get your podcasts. Bad Dates.
我们依然会听到听众发来的真实信件和语音留言，分享他们自己最糟糕的约会经历，此外乔尔也会分享他在约会战场上漫长而离奇的时光。我们喜欢这个节目，因为每个人都经历过这些，每个人都能感同身受。现在是时候在《糟糕约会》第二季中，和你的新主持人乔尔·金·布斯特一起嘲笑这些经历了。快来看看这个节目片段，并在你收听播客的任何地方关注《糟糕约会》。《糟糕约会》。
And now the very funny Justin Martindale. So it was a nice summer evening. This was probably about like almost, I want to say 10 years ago. Oh, wow. A child. You were a baby. No, I'll say like seven. Still am. Uh. Um.
现在有请非常风趣的贾斯汀·马丁代尔。那是一个美好的夏夜。这大概是快，我想说大概10年前的事了。哦，哇。还是个孩子。你当时还是个宝宝。不，我会说大概七年前。我现在还是。呃。嗯。
So I went to the show. It was a show here in LA. And I met this guy and the lighting was just good. And I was very inebriated. And we were talking, we kind of hit it off. We started making out. And the lighting was just good, and I was very inebriated. And we were talking, we kind of hit it off. We started making out, and then we exchanged numbers. And he was living in New York, I was in LA, so we were like, we're gonna just do this
所以我去看了演出。那是洛杉矶的一场演出。我遇到了这个家伙，灯光正好。我当时喝得很醉。我们聊得很投机，一见如故。我们开始亲热。灯光正好，我当时喝得很醉。我们聊得很投机，一见如故。我们开始亲热，然后交换了电话号码。他住在纽约，我在洛杉矶，所以我们当时想，我们要开始这段
bi-coastal long-distance fantasy. And one day, if destiny allows us, we will meet up again, right? We started talking regularly on the phone, and this was kind of before FaceTime kind of took off. So we were just like talking and flirting, and, you know, he started talking about like, so when are you gonna come to New York?
跨越东西海岸的异地恋幻想。如果命运允许，总有一天我们会再见面的，对吧？我们开始频繁地通电话，那是在FaceTime流行之前。所以我们只是聊天、调情，你知道，他开始说，那你什么时候来纽约？
And I'll make this like great weekend for us. And I'm like, okay, sure, yeah, let's make it happen. So finally, I wanna say like November, sure, yeah, let's make it happen. So finally, I want to say like November, maybe like a couple days before Thanksgiving, I got a flight, went out to New York, and I'm waiting at the airport for him to pick me up. He shows up and I'm like, I don't know this person. Like he didn't look like the guy that I had seen that night.
我会为你安排一个很棒的周末。我说，好的，没问题，让我们实现它吧。所以终于，我想说大概是11月，没问题，让我们实现它吧。所以终于，我想说大概是11月，可能就在感恩节前几天，我买了机票去了纽约，在机场等他来接我。他出现了，我心想，我不认识这个人。他看起来不像我那天晚上见到的那个人。
Of course, it was blurry and shadowy, but I was like, oh no. And New York can do a lot of damage to your- In a month, yeah, a couple months. Yeah, a couple months in New York. A couple months can change people. He was just like not the person that I remember. Do you think you got twin switch?
当然，当时光线模糊，但我心想，哦不。纽约可能会对你的……在一个月里，是的，几个月。是的，在纽约待了几个月。几个月可以改变一个人。他看起来根本不是我记忆中的那个人。你觉得你被双胞胎掉包了吗？
Do you think? Oh, I never thought about that. I got parents wrapped, oh my God. Yeah, seriously, a twin catfish. So we go into his apartment and I'm looking at his place and I'm like, oh, this is really weird. He had like a trench coat that was nailed to the wall and I was like, what is that?
你觉得呢？哦，我从来没想过。我被双胞胎骗了，天哪。是的，说真的，双胞胎钓鱼。我们走进他的公寓，我看着他的住处，心想，哦，这真的很奇怪。他墙上钉着一件风衣，我心想，那是什么？
And he was like, well, I love musical theater. And I'm like, shit, like immediately. Cause I'm not like a big musical theater gay. That's a logical response. Yeah, what musical is that referencing? That trench coat nailed you well. I am so glad you asked because he had stolen Lea Michele's trench coat
他说，哦，我热爱音乐剧。我心想，该死，立刻就想到了。因为我不是那种超级音乐剧迷。这是个合理的反应。是的，那件钉在墙上的风衣是指哪部音乐剧？我很高兴你问了，因为他偷了丽娅·米雪儿的风衣
when she was eponine in Les Mis. Oh my God. Well, he just shot up in my estimation, I gotta say. Nailed it to his wall. Like it wasn't even in a frame. It was just a trench coat crucified to the wall. So I'm like, oh, okay. And he had like a whole bunch of like other little Broadway
当她在《悲惨世界》里演爱潘妮的时候。天哪。好吧，我不得不说，他在我心里的地位瞬间提升了。把它钉在墙上。甚至都没装进框里。就像一件被钉在十字架上的风衣。所以我心想，哦，好吧。而且他还有一大堆其他的小百老汇
knickknacks and everything. He didn't have time to steal a frame. What was the issue? Steal a frame. Like do something, like what, it looks weird. We hadn't have time to steal a frame. What was the bitch doing? Steal a frame. Like do something, like it looks weird. We hadn't made any moves on each other. We hadn't even like kissed. It was just very, very, very awkward.
纪念品之类的。他没时间去偷个框。有什么问题吗？偷个框。做点什么，比如，这看起来很奇怪。我们没时间去偷个框。那混蛋在干什么？偷个框。做点什么，这看起来很奇怪。我们之间没有任何进展。我们甚至没接吻。这真的、真的、非常尴尬。
And then finally he's like, I have a surprise for you. I got us tickets to go see Wicked. And so I had never seen Wicked. I was like, okay, cool. this is a Broadway show, fine. He got us like orchestra seats. They were really good seats. And he said, I need you to be the lookout. You have to stand near the door.
最后他说，我有个惊喜给你。我买了票带你去看《魔法坏女巫》。我从来没看过《魔法坏女巫》。我说，好的，酷。这是百老汇演出，行吧。他买了管弦乐队区的票。座位真的很好。他说，我需要你帮我放哨。你必须站在门附近。
Yeah. I have to watch Elphaba so you don't steal her hat, right? Yeah. The story is also very boil the frog. Like you're like, okay, all right. Yeah, I don't want to be a bad sport. You know, I'm like, I don't want to seem like I'm not grateful. Well, you flew across the country and I'm assuming coach.
是的。我得盯着艾尔法巴，这样你就不会偷她的帽子，对吧？是的。这个故事也很有“温水煮青蛙”的感觉。就像你心想，好吧，行吧。是的，我不想扫兴。你知道，我心想，我不想显得我不领情。好吧，你飞越了整个国家，我假设是经济舱。
Yes, I did. You weren't in Delta One back then. No, not, not bad. You know, middle seat back row. Like by the toilet. So we ended up going to see Wicked, and I'd never seen Wicked, and it starts out and it's all grand and everything. And then I realized, like, I'm hearing something
是的，我坐的是经济舱。你当时可没坐达美航空的头等舱。不，不，不坏。你知道，最后一排的中间座位。就在厕所旁边。所以我们最终去看了《魔法坏女巫》，我从来没看过，演出开始了，一切都很宏大。然后我意识到，我听到了一些
that's not part of the show. And so I look over and he is belting every song like he is in the show. Like every song. And I'm mortified. I'm sitting there and I'm like, shut the fuck up. To the point where one of the flying monkeys in one of the numbers looks at us and hushes us.
不属于演出的声音。所以我看过去，他正在跟着唱每一首歌，就像他在演出一样。每一首歌都是。我感到非常羞愧。我坐在那里心想，闭嘴吧。以至于其中一个飞猴在表演时看着我们，让我们安静点。
I have never been hushed. To be hushed by a flying monkey? By Chistery? Hushed by a flying monkey, which is not a CBS sitcom. Yeah, it's not good. The flying monkey's looking at you like, be more civilized, please. Seriously.
我从来没被人要求安静过。被一只飞猴要求安静？被奇斯特里？被一只飞猴要求安静，这可不是什么CBS的情景喜剧。是的，这可不好。那只飞猴看着你，好像在说，请文明一点。说真的。
Returns to screeching, jumping around. And he, I'm like, you have to shut up. And he's like, okay, sorry, sorry. It's like my favorite musical. I've seen it like 800 times. And I'm like, okay, well, I've never seen it. So shut the fuck up. So am I having like, does he sing every time
又回去尖叫跳跃了。我心想，你必须闭嘴。他说，好的，抱歉，抱歉。这是我最喜欢的音乐剧。我已经看过大概800次了。我说，好吧，但我从来没看过。所以闭嘴吧。所以我是不是……他每次都唱吗
or is it for you? Do you know what I mean? Yeah, I have no idea. He was just like, was it for you or was he hoping a casting director was in the audience? Probably, probably so, probably so. We went and saw Bring It On as well, and I don't remember that musical. It was so bad.
还是专门为你唱的？你明白我的意思吗？是的，我不知道。他只是……是为你唱的，还是他希望观众席里有选角导演？可能吧，可能吧，可能吧。我们还去看了《魅力四射》，我不记得那部音乐剧了。太糟糕了。
It was just, I couldn't do it. But the same thing. And he was just like, you know, curtain call came out and he was like, I couldn't do it. But the same thing. And he was just like, you know, curtain call came out and he was like, Natalie! Natalie! Natalie! Natalie! Yes!
我实在受不了。但同样的事情又发生了。他只是，你知道，谢幕的时候，他喊着，我实在受不了。但同样的事情又发生了。他只是，你知道，谢幕的时候，他喊着，娜塔莉！娜塔莉！娜塔莉！娜塔莉！是的！
And I'm just like, mm. I've been sending you the packages. I've been sending you the packages, Natalie. He's like, girl, you nailed it, girl! And like, Natalie's not even like looking. Like, it was just, it was awful. And that was it. And did you ever hear from this man again?
我心想，嗯。我一直在给你寄包裹。我一直在给你寄包裹，娜塔莉。他说，天哪，你太棒了，天哪！娜塔莉甚至都没看他。这简直太糟糕了。就是这样。你后来还有这个男人的消息吗？
No, I didn't. But, I mean, can I get a little dark? It was awful and that was it. And did you ever hear from this man again? No, I didn't, but I mean, can I get a little dark? Oh boy. Please. Oh no. He died. You tell us that after we've been riffing on him, making fun of him. That's it for you.
没有，我没有。但是，我可以稍微阴暗一点吗？这简直太糟糕了，就是这样。你后来还有这个男人的消息吗？没有，我没有，但是，我可以稍微阴暗一点吗？哦天哪。请讲。哦不。他死了。你居然在我们嘲笑他、拿他开玩笑之后才告诉我们。你真是够了。
I got like a memory on Facebook and I was like, oh yeah, that guy. And I clicked and it was like, this is like an in memoriam like account now. And I was like, oh no Facebook and I was like, oh yeah, that guy. And I clicked and it was like, this is like an in memoriam like account now. And I was like, oh no, but I will say, because I knew him, I have been changed for good. So. Wow.
我在Facebook上看到了一个回忆提醒，心想，哦对，那个家伙。我点进去，发现这现在是一个纪念账号。我心想，哦不，Facebook，我心想，哦对，那个家伙。我点进去，发现这现在是一个纪念账号。我心想，哦不，但我得说，因为认识他，我的人生被彻底改变了。所以。哇。
Fuck you. Fuck you. Do you know if he died doing what he loved? Stealing Broadway memorabilia? So I don't know. I wonder who got the Liam Michelle trench. Yeah. Do you know if he died doing what he loved, stealing Broadway memorabilia? Let's hope. I don't know. I wonder who got the Lea Michele trench. Yeah.
去你的。去你的。你知道他死的时候是在做他热爱的事吗？偷百老汇纪念品？所以我不知道。我很好奇是谁拿走了那件丽娅·米雪儿的风衣。是的。你知道他死的时候是在做他热爱的事吗，偷百老汇纪念品？希望如此。我不知道。我很好奇是谁拿走了那件丽娅·米雪儿的风衣。是的。
I know. Right? Who got that in the estate sale? He probably was trying to sneak backstage and get something from Funny Girl and Lea Michele stand her ground laws, shock him. Yeah. I know. This is so dark.
我知道，对吧？谁在遗产拍卖会上拿到了那个？他可能当时正试图溜进后台，想从《妙女郎》里偷点什么，结果丽娅·米雪儿的“坚守阵地法”把他电死了。是的。我知道。这太阴暗了。
We have to stop. Geez. Bad Dates wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们得停下来。天哪。《糟糕约会》，在你收听播客的任何地方收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。